i'm such a big fan of shonda i'm so glad
to see you i just want to applaud you
and say thank you for this season
uh bridgeton to see two south asian
women as leading roles it is something
that i've been waiting for so long so
thank you thank you thank you
was the season everything you wanted
yes you know it was so exciting for it
to come together this way and you know
to get to work on it and to jump right
in you know we were very excited for it
to come together
yeah you know following in your journey
and everything that you've done and i
was on your social media yesterday and
the fact there's a barbie
that looks like you
i'm still my mind is still blown about
that as somebody who spent her entire
childhood playing with the little black
barbie cara doll
to have a barbie that looks like me is
insane i still haven't wrapped my mind
around it yet who's the first person you
gave the barbie to
um i
my barbie is still like sealed in a box
my daughter's like played with it for a
little bit and then i sealed it in a box
and i was like it just has to stay there
and be special oh
i love that and then one of the biggest
stars of this season is the dog newton
everyone is talking about newton uh what
was it
that dog is that dog is a star i've got
to tell you
yeah was it hard was he behaving on set
was it easy to work with a dog or is it
harder to work with humans from what i
hear that dog was a diva in a good way
um as as dogs should be so i think it's
pretty great that we got a dog going
into the show and the dog was wonderful
and how would you describe season two
compared to season one from your own
experiences what were some of the
challenges for you or what was different
for you for this this time around
you know season two the books are very
different from season one and the story
is very different it's it's much more of
a slow burn for the couple and you know
you're sort of filled with anticipation
of waiting and waiting and waiting and
watching something build up so you know
it's very different in that way and i
think that you know you're sort of on
the edge of your seat for most of season
two and that's a different thing and so
the challenge was to really
build in this world of heat and passion
and steam like while getting people to
you know wait for the big you know the
big moments to happen and shonda like
from inventing anna to this show season
two you're just like killing it what do
you want to do next
oh well right now you know i'm working
on you know the queen charlotte prequel
um that's based you know on bridgerton
which is going to be a story about queen
charlotte as she's coming together but
there's so much i want to do next i'm
having a great time right now i'm loving
my job yeah
yeah what did what have you learned
about yourself through this process
because this takes in us into a
different era and you're bringing
diversity into it and you're showing it
in a very different way that's really
speaking to people so
what has that meant for you to be able
to do something like that
you know it's i always keep saying this
to people that like talking about
diversity and inclusion is only
uh
a look a luxury as a in a conversation
for people who are always included
if you're not a person who's always
included it's a it's just a necessity so
this is not like a it's not a big deal
in because
simply because you know if i haven't
always been included then i'm just going
to make sure that that's a thing that
happens it's just the way it's going to
be
so for us it's just been wonderful we've
been having a great time and we've been
telling stories that we love and we've
been telling stories about characters as
they should be told
well said well said i love that
20th anniversary of crossroads he was on
your social media which is really
exciting can you believe it's been that
long and i gotta ask what do you think
of this whole idea of uh brittany being
free finally
oh wow um
gave the 20th anniversary of crossroads
gay for brittany for if she's living the
life that she wants and i think that
that's the most important thing i think
all women should be living the lives
they want
i love that congratulations to you and
the show and i'm such a big fan of yours
and and the show so thank you so much
for creating such magic i think that's
the right word for it thank you thanks
everyone bye